hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news coming up on today's
program
charging points for electric vehicles in
all new homes from next year but are
measures like this enough to tackle the
climate crisis
the chief executive of qatar 2022 tells
sky news the world cup will be the
greenest yet
and we meet the woman behind an
environmental organization on a mission
to stop plastic pollution
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions and one of those solutions is
often hailed as electric vehicles with
the government announcing today that
from next year charging points for evs
will be legally required in all new
build homes as part of efforts to help
the uk reach net zero emissions by 2050.
here's what the prime minister had to
say earlier
we're regulating so as to require new
homes and buildings to have ev charging
points with another 145 000 charging
points to be installed thanks to these
regulations we're investing in new
projects to turn wind power into
hydrogen and the net zero strategy is
expected to trigger about 90 billion
pounds of private sector investment
driving the creation of high-wage
high-skilled jobs across the uk
as part of our mission to unite and
level up across the country
our climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter joins me now hello to you hannah
is this going to make a big difference
or is it just tinkering round the edges
by the government
well surface transport is one of the key
sectors that the government knows it has
to decarbonize almost entirely if it's
going to hit its net zero targets um
cars and taxis constitute about 16
uh of all carbon emissions um annually
from the from the uk and so
electrification as far as the government
is concerned is the answer
the criticism has been that
infrastructure doesn't exist to support
electric vehicles
not on street charging
posts and lamp posts and so on and not
in not
on the edges of homes and so those two
problems need to be addressed this is
specifically targeted at individual
homes it's hoped that it will create
some 145 000 extra
charging points every year so this will
have an impact if it is rolled out as
promised but the criticisms continue
in relation to the government's promises
um
on
electrifying our transport network and
and that is
um that there are it's very hard to do
this in a in a leveled way that there
are
already charging black spots in small
towns for example in areas where homes
do not have driveways and particularly
in rural areas so to make sure that
everyone has equitable access to the
electrical
vehicle charging network and
the separate argument of course is a is
all of the problems around the
affordability of electric cars in the
first place um the government has to
change the law to change the structure
of our lives so that we can electrify
our lives which is what they hope will
decarbonize this hugely emitting sector
hannah thank you
and we're going to be talking about this
further in today's climate show debate
with the economist vicki price and
donica mccarthy climate columnist at the
independent that is coming up in a few
minutes time
let's take a look at some of today's
other climate news now london has been
named the most vegan-friendly and
future-ready city in the world by a
billion a tech company that aims to
encourage sustainable living a billion
assessed cities on how much they've
embraced plant-based lifestyles their
commitment to green policies greenhouse
gas emissions and waste generation
london earned its top spot based on
immense progress on emissions transport
green spaces air quality and clean
energy
one of the biggest fossil fuel projects
in australia has been given final
approval that's despite being labeled a
disaster by environmentalists production
at the oil and gas field is set to start
in 2026 and will have 30 wells drilled
over its lifetime the scarborough
project is a venture between energy
giants woodside and bhp who've merged to
create one of the world's biggest fossil
fuel companies
and the prince of wales has met with the
president of israel at highgrove isaac
herzog tweeted that he and prince
charles discussed the crime crisis
crisis and potential for regional
cooperation after the meeting israel's
government recently announced actions to
reach net zero by 2050 including rolling
out green infrastructure and developing
carbon capture and storage technology
it is just under a year to go until the
2022 world cup kicks off in qatar and
the tournament's boss has told sky news
he thinks it will be the greenest yet
nasa alcatra was speaking to our sports
correspondent tom parmenter
each stadium has been built with legacy
in mind so every stadium has a purpose
after the tournament some of them will
be going to football clubs where they
have really
old facilities a lot of these old
football clubs are in uh highly dense
residential areas
so
when they get their new stadiums they'll
it'll be the new home for their clubs
when we talk about the environment uh
one key thing was
how do we improve environmental
awareness and how do we improve the
environmental sustainability of the
country the state has built two
or is building two solar power
generation plants of 600 megawatts each
and i think that's a massive um
benefit of the world cup as well
so this will be probably the greenest
tournament
that to date
yes
mainly and one big factor is the compact
nature of qatar the elimination of air
travel from city to city for the teams
for fans and so forth
goes a long way to also
decreasing the carbon footprint
and tom joins me now hello tom it is a
laudable aim is it as good as as it
sounds
well they're trying to sell it as the
first carbon neutral world cup and there
are quite a few levers that they are
pulling as part of that as you heard
there it will be one international
flight for most people attending the
world cup into doha and then there'll be
no domestic air travel because all the
stadiums are within an hour of each
other that is a big difference because
perhaps in previous world cups in brazil
and russia we've seen fans and teams
traveling enormous distances a lot of
internal flights as part of the world
cup as they progress through the
tournament and that simply won't happen
in qatar it's all very compact and that
is a big factor in reducing the
footprint but nevertheless there will
still be a big footprint because you've
got lots of people flying into one place
from all over the world and 95 of the
emissions will come from transportation
of people arriving into qatar from
various continents and also the
construction and accommodation so
it is inevitably going to have a big
footprint but they want to try and
offset that and you cannot obviously
offset it but there are also other
things to consider when you look at
qatar this is the first winter world cup
so
that is because it is simply too hot to
play there during the heat of the summer
and also you have to bear in mind that
qatar is one of the world's biggest
natural gas and a major oil producer as
well and then the other considerations
of human rights a lot of spotlight on
the conditions that workers have been in
as they've constructed those stadiums
and of course equalities because this is
a country where homosexuality is against
the law the organizers say everyone is
welcome but
i have to say the environmental
sustainability of the tournament is
probably
at the fore now in the planning of this
st of this tournament and probably is as
high up the list of priorities as it's
ever been tom you touched on the issue
of flights whatever measures are taken
in qatar can a big global sporting event
like this ever truly be sustainable
well they're doing their best they say
and each world cup we're seeing
incremental progress on sustainability
but you can't have an empty tournament
you need people there to make it a
tournament to make it a world cup and
therefore
the offset process will be part of how
they try to make it carbon neutral but
you can never reduce the footprint to
nothing because you have this enormous
gathering of people this time in the
desert there will be some big benefits
that come from it a much cleaner
transport system in doha for example but
the
net gain i suppose is that each world
cup tries to improve on the last and
qatar is trying to set new standards and
inevitably um they are pushing the
boundaries to try to underline their
green credentials as they face the gaze
of the world's media as we're now one
year to go and that will only get bigger
as we go through to next winter when
this world cup will kick off yeah the
countdown is on tom thank you very much
indeed
well let's take a look at our data
dashboard now and see where electricity
in great britain is coming from
right now around 47
is coming from gas at 5.5 coming from
coal and
21.9
coming from renewable sources if you've
been outside you'll know it's been a
cold but a sunny day across many parts
of the country today and that has meant
more power from solar providing around
nine percent of the mix earlier on that
is compared to an average of around 1.4
for the rest of this month solar panels
in fact perform better in cooler weather
so we do tend to see solar generation
records in late april when britain's
more likely to experience strong
sunshine and lower
temperatures now millions of tonnes of
plastic waste ends up in our oceans
around the world and now campaigners are
targeting some common household objects
wanting to change the way they're
manufactured in the latest in our series
of climate diaries we're meeting natalie
fee an award-winning environmentalist
and founder of city to see
i'm natalie fay and i'm the founder of
city to see
we're a not-for-profit campaigning to
stop plastic pollution at source
we tend to campaign on the top 10
most commonly found plastic items on our
beaches things like plastic bottles and
bottle top caps and we do that primarily
through our refill campaign
[Music]
a cheeky little refill
[Music]
we also developed an app which is
stopping hundreds of millions of pieces
of plastic from entering the waste
stream connecting people to places they
can refill their water bottle they can
refill their household goods and coffee
cups and things like that as well
i'm working towards a future in which
plastic on beaches and plastic harming
our marine animals becomes a thing of
the past and we have designed pointless
plastic out of the waste system and we
are refilling our way to a truly
circular economy
do stay with us because coming up after
the break i'm going to be joined by the
economist vicki price and the
independence climate columnist donica
mccarthy we're going to be discussing if
policies like more electric vehicle
charging points go far enough and
whether climate protests could look
different in the future we'll see in a
couple minutes
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
economist vicki price and donica
mccarthy climate columnist at the
independence
now as we heard earlier developers will
have to install electric vehicle
charging points at new homes workplaces
and supermarkets from next year but with
25 million homes still heated by a gas
boiler many of them with poor insulation
should the government be doing more to
accelerate the green transition
vicki downing street is today described
this as a world-beating plan is it
well it's a very interesting idea to
force um builders to
rethink the way in which they put
together the houses or when you're
looking at perhaps uh i think it's
included too in what we heard today um
restructuring your building or
renovating or changing the the the use
of a particular building that you can
actually now
or you have to be um forced to add
charging points to for electric vehicles
and it does make quite a lot of sense in
my view but of course we're talking
about new homes uh quite a lot of homes
right now as we know don't have even
driveways where they can park their cars
so it will require quite a lot of
rethinking in terms of where those
charging points really are put and i
think just putting them in the new homes
isn't going to be the answer what people
need given that we now have something
like 10 of new cars being sold being
electric you need proper public charging
points you need to be able to get into a
petrol station of source if you like
and use it just like if you're using it
now for normal fuel and be able to
recharge your batteries quite easily and
quickly which is something that we're
still a long long way from being able to
get to have got to really uh it requires
battery production to improve battery
technology to improve and loads more
charging points to be available across a
large part of the uk where it's present
there are big gaps london and southeast
is well provided by comparison quite a
lot of the rest of the uk isn't
yeah and the clock is ticking isn't it
because we know that new petrol and
diesel cars are being phased out by
2030. there's no choice the government's
got to do something donald does this
plan go far and fast enough
it's a tiny step in a direction for
better facilities for evs but of course
what the government's totally ignoring
is actually the need for us to be moving
away from a car culture in our cities 83
of the united kingdom public live in
towns and cities and what we need to be
doing there is investing in cycle lanes
and public transport and we've been
going in the opposite direction on that
public transport has in real terms had
its uh prices increased above inflation
every year for the last 10 years whilst
actually they've reduced the the the
fossil fuel duties for cars and our
investment in um cycle lane
infrastructure is abysmal it's around a
tenth of what the united nations says we
need to be spending
vicki we talked about gas boilers we
talked about home insulation um
in the wider scheme of things
how big a deal is this
ah it's it's not immense i have to say i
think the most important thing of all is
to think about this you know public
charging places that we absolutely need
uh but of course uh the interesting
thing is that when you're looking at how
we might move around in the future of
course i take the point that perhaps we
need to be rethinking whether we use a
car in in cities as much as we do at
present
we've also got a different
element in terms of
how we'll power our cars hydrogen is
being developed now as the possibility
of replacing uh petrol as the main fuel
for cars and if that's the case then
quite a lot of those electric uh
charging points may in fact not be
needed so the balance between the two is
going to be really quite important so
what the government i think is doing
which i think is reasonably clever
is saying that we're not going to be
investing anything ourselves we're
having a law which is going to force
those charging points to appear so
they're not actually spending anything
particularly much on this whereas when
it comes to really investing in hydrogen
technology the government is going to
have to absolutely sit down with
all the the whole the industry and
participate and also share some of the
risk of that so this is a low risk
strategy for them but i think they're
going to need to think a lot more widely
than that well let's discuss our second
topic now because from shutting down
cities to skipping school protest action
from groups like extinction rebellion
and friday's for future have shown a
spotlight on the climate crisis now
police could be given more powers to
crack down on protests as part of a new
policing bill put forward by the
government under the new measures
officers could cancel demonstrations for
being too noisy as well as confiscating
items like superglue to stop activists
from attaching themselves to buildings
and of course rose donaka this comes
about in the wake of the very high
profile
protests by insulate britain do you
think it's going to make a difference do
you think it will be a deterrent
i think what the one area where the
government is delivering on its promises
on climate is on its promises to crack
down on climate protests and it's really
disturbing what direction they're moving
in they're beginning to equate peaceful
protests with terrorism introducing a
law that puts people in jail for 10
years for being seriously annoying is
something you'd expect in communist
china or putin's russia
and and the new proposals that actually
that they're now beginning to use
injunctions which bypasses the right the
human right to jury trial is really
disturbing putting people in in front of
the court that with an unlimited fine an
unlimited sign for peacefully sitting
protesting on a road is not something we
should be accepting in a liberal
democracy and it's really disturbing
however we have to
acknowledge that every single human
rights movement in the world in the last
100 years governments have cracked down
on it people have gone to jail and then
the human rights have been established
the tragedy is how many young people
in grief and despair lack of action by
the government will end up in jail to
try and get the government to do what's
needed and the judge who jailed nine uh
recent insulate britain protesters said
that while weighing up the rights to
protest also weighing up uh the rights
of individuals to go about their daily
lives at vicky yougov poll has found
that 18 of people in the uk support the
actions of insulate britain
they have certainly got their message
across they have certainly made their
purpose known so does that constitute a
success
i would imagine that uh that it is i
mean they have to watch what they do in
the future obviously if these laws are
indeed uh um passed and and that's how
they have to
watch what they're doing in the future
but um
they have certainly made everyone much
more aware of some of the issues but uh
you know people warm to that if you like
one can use that expression but we do
know that the costs are enormous and
they're enormous for individuals and the
questions
i'm sorry to cut you off but vicky and
donica we are out of time thank you very
much indeed uh for that discussion today
that is everything from us this evening
on tomorrow's show i'll be joined by the
guardian columnist george monbio and
julia king baroness brown of cambridge
to discuss all of the big climate
stories of the day but do stay tuned
because coming up next here on sky news
tonight we will have the latest from the
police in wisconsin after a car hit a
christmas parade in the state leaving at
least five people dead thanks for
watching we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you